[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi 6
décembre tout de suite les titres de
l'actualité
l'hiver période de vigilance renforcée
sur les routes du département comment
s'organisent les collectivités en cette
saison où la neige notamment peut créer
des perturbations réponse au travers de
deux exemples à saint quentin en
yvelines et au conseil départemental qui
assurent la viabilité des axes avec son
voisin des hauts de seine
et demain c'est le début du 32e téléthon
le week-end marathon pour soutenir la
recherche contre les maladies génétiques
rares comme chaque année les l'île de
saint quentin en yvelines sont
pleinement engagés invité serge poyotte
ans et daniel tamam organisateurs des
téléthons à guyancourt et magny les
hameaux
et puis c'est un projet qui promet une
alimentation santé et plaisir pour les
seniors silver fourchette a lancé sa
programmation d'événements dans les
yvelines
point d'orgue un concours de cuisine des
chefs d etat du département pour en
parler eléonore padovani chef de projet
silver fourchette yvelines ce chiffre
pour commencer cent quarante six
individus interpellés ce matin devant le
lycée jean rostand à mantes la jolie
après des heurts avec les forces de
l'ordre depuis le début de la semaine
l'établissement étaient bloquées dans le
cadre de la mobilisation des lycéens
contre parcours super la réforme du bac
une action qui a dégénéré plusieurs
bouteilles de gaz notamment ont été
retrouvés aux abords du lycée des
incidents sont également à signaler à
poissy conflans sainte honorine et en
début de semaine à la queue-lez-yvelines
montfort mélanie poker avec la baisse
des températures arrive souvent la neige
vous avez sans doute gardé en mémoire
l'épisode neigeux de février dernier
alors sur les routes c'était la pagaille
près de 7 139 km de ralentissements en
ile de france
rappelez-vous certains ont dû abandonner
leur véhicule en bord de route
les yvelines ont connu une première
alerte au mois de novembre même si les
flocons n'ont pas tenu et les
collectivités sont déjà en alerte ont
fait le point avec vous mais la niche
département est mobilisée depuis le 12
novembre il ya d'ailleurs eu un premier
salage préventif le 20 novembre dernier
pour les chutes dont vous parlez
ce plan est installée jusqu'à la mi mars
deux centres d'exploitation sont
opérationnels saint cyr l'école et
orgeval avec cinq agents ils sont
d'astreinte chaque semaine pour faire du
salage préventif des 450 km de routes
départementales de secteurs urbains il
faut savoir qu'en plus de nos agents on
a un responsable d'astreinte sur
l'ensemble de ce secteur qui lui est
plus chargé de surveiller la météo la
veille au soir d'organiser des sorties
en tant que de besoin en fonction de ses
prévisions météorologiques
les interventions se décide pas au pied
levé en général c'est l'après midi du
l'après midi on décide si on va sortir
la nuit et en fonction des prévisions
météorologiques ont également capable
d'anticiper si la situation va être
critique sur deux trois quatre jours et
une douzaine d'agriculteurs prêter
main-forte main-forte pardon aux agents
pour dégager certaines voies de
circulation mélanie l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines a aussi son
plan hivernal et ce plan là lui a débuté
le 1er décembre dernier et doit prendre
fin du côté du 31 mars
l'an passé les agents ont même travaillé
au delà de ces dates
alors pour les douze communes ce sont
douze engins qui sont prêts à intervenir
en fonction de la météo et un engin de
secours pour suppléer en cas de panne ou
d'incident ce sont dix personnes qui
sont en charge des 320 kilomètres au
sein de l'agglomération
l'objectif est de rendre les voies
carrossables ou empêcher qu'elles ne
deviennent difficiles de circulation
donc c'est du préventif d'abord avant
toute chose en fonction des bulletins
météo du salage de la saumure la saumure
qui est non polluante qui préserve la
qui préserve l'environnement et qui est
plus efficace efficace que le salage
traditionnels alors pour être tenu
informé saint quentin en yvelines vous
invite à vous inscrire sur le site peps
points ce qui point fr il suffit juste
d'entrer votre adresse mail pour
recevoir les alertes y faisait parler
des routes qu'en est il des trottoirs
mais là dessus alors si on arrêtait du
maire le prévoit c'est à vous de
déneiger le trottoir de vendre votre
domicile il faut donc déblayer la neige
est assurée le sablage ou le salage en
cas de verglas et surtout ne pas
obstruer les bouches d'égout
le non respect de ces mesures vous
expose à 38 euros d'amendé mais pour le
moment pas d'inquiétude la neige
n'est pas annoncée merci mélanie pour
cette chronique dans l'actualité les
présidents des départements
d'ile-de-france où l'ag hauts-de-seine
seine-saint-denis et val-de-marne ne
seront pas supprimée et fusionnée dans
la métropole du grand paris ce projet du
gouvernement a été abandonnée c'est la
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
jacqueline gourault qu il annoncé aux
représentants des collectivités
rappelez-vous le dossier avait suscité
un tollé dans la région et avait donné
lieu à une mobilisation commune 17
départements franciliens une action
inédite réunissant différentes
sensibilités politiques
elle fait partie des 30 villes en france
à vouloir l'appliquer la verrière
souhaite la mise en oeuvre rapide de
l'encadrement des loyers pour son parc
privé annonce faite hier la mesure est
rendue possible par la loi élan publié
au journal officiel en novembre le texte
permet d expérimentation de cinq ans
dans les zones dites tendues l'objectif
c'est de maîtriser le niveau des loyers
pour endiguer d'éventuelles hausses
pour le moment le décret sur
l'encadrement des loyers ne figure pas
au journal officiel pas deux
publications avant février d'ici là de
nombreux points restent à définir
notamment le montant et des ailes loyer
médian le monde de l'immobilier
d'entreprise a rendez vous au palais des
congrès à paris pendant trois jours les
acteurs de cette activité se sont
rassemblés pour la 17e édition du salon
d'immobilier d'entreprise parmi eux
saint quentin en yvelines et paris
saclay ou encore le département des
yvelines avec leurs partenaires privés
reportage de nicolas landry ce bâtiment
de 18 mille mètres carrés s'appelle
native un projet de démolition
reconstruction place choiseul à montigny
le bretonneux opérationnel en 2021 avec
un bail déjà signé avec l'entreprise
orange l'opération est menée par le
groupe codic promoteurs immobiliers
présents sur le territoire depuis 2000
vraiment 50 à être
très belle cour de récréation pour nous
c'est une ville qui a été construite
très rapidement dans les années 60 70
donc il ya pas mal de bâti à reconvertir
ex que nous pouvons offrir à ses 1 40-1
c'est de venir avec des architectes de
renom saint-quentin-en-yvelines ses prix
de 5 millions de m² d'immobilier
d'entreprise 2018 une année record avec
222 1500 mètres carrés de transactions
et un taux de vacance de 5 5% et une
complémentarité avec les autres
territoires de paris saclay on a ce
travail avec eux de mise en connexion de
tout le pôle économique de saint quentin
en yvelines avec les forces académique
de recherche sur l'ensemble de paris
saclay paris saclay ses trois pôles un
pôle culturel à versailles un pôle
économique donc à saint quentin et un
pôle scientifique à saclay donc les
trois poules travaillent ensemble à
preuves et on est également dans le même
conseil d'administration qui s'appelle
le pea paris saclay en soit
régulièrement le simi l'occasion aussi
de nouer de nouvelles relations c'est le
cas avec cicas hospitality exploitant
hôtelier présent en angleterre et aux
pays bas
il ya énormément d'entreprises c'est
quelque chose de sain territoire
dynamique qui est et reste une zone
d'attrait pour beaucoup de clients
corporate et donc de fait peuvent
générer des nuitées pour nos hôtels sur
saint quentin en yvelines 250 mille
mètres carrés de projets d'immobilier
d'entreprise sont en cours de
développement
c'est le week-end marathon pour la
recherche contre les maladies et
génétique rare la 32e édition du
téléthon c'est à partir de demain
et comme d'habitude à saint quentin en
yvelines un programme chargé à retenir
notamment un à premier téléthon
d'ampleur à coignières on va peut-être
voir le programme s'afficher dans un
instant à qui se mobilisent samedi au
gymnase du moulin à vent ça y est le
programme s'affiche ce premier téléthon
à coignières marylène iapichino parlera
dans son émission 7 8 loisirs du
téléthon à montigny le bretonneux
le programme dans vos communes
respectives à retrouver bien sûr sur les
différents sites internet
alors deux invités avec moi en plateau
de villes représentées serge poignant
bonsoir bonsoir d'être le président de
j'ai deuxième j'ai dit en cours
manifestation pour les maladies
génétique bonsoir daniel tama minceur
vous êtes le président d'objectif
téléthon manie quoi donc deux villes
représentées sur ce plateau
vous organisez dans vos villes
respectives le programme du téléthon
déjà un petit tour de table pour
commencer pourquoi c'est important de se
mobiliser demain dernier prison alors
pour moi c'est important c'est de
récolter ce matin nous en parle c'est
important de récolter un maximum
d'argent dans pour améliorer le confort
des enfants très malades ou très
lourdement handicapé pour soulager la
peine les parents qui sont souvent très
très digne mais qui souffre
intérieurement comme des très grandes
souffrances et pour aider les chercheurs
à toujours davantage progressé parce
qu'aujourd'hui la recherche couteau
toujours de plus en plus cher que c'est
important la souffrance aussi de la
famille voilà la souffrance la famille
les parents sont très dignes mais
souffre intérieur romain et suse 10 ans
a pour aider leurs enfants qui sont
souvent qu'ils ont dû souvent bondés
lourd handicap pour la présence de la
maladie pour rendre les enfants heureux
parce que les enfants sont d'un courage
extraordinaire bien souvent ils n'ont
connaît les inscrire qu'une chose c'est
apprendre jouer avec tout le monde
communiquer avec tout le monde dont il
faut leur offrir je pense le plus grand
confort possible dans leur maladie
daniel tammet mme serge prison a dit
beaucoup de choses pourquoi vous sévit
mobilisés ah mais non il a effectivement
vu par cette mobilisation est importante
pour la recherche avant tout et puis si
j'ai bien dit l'aide aux familles mais
surtout la recherche
il ya des avancées aujourd'hui ces
avancées elles se font grâce à la
collecte au bon il faut collecter
week-end très chargé dans vos communes
la préparation on imagine qui a été très
longue alors pour le programme amani ça
débute demain demain soir à 19h et c'est
jusqu'au lendemain samedi 10 heures au
gymnase chantal mauduit finalement ça
être un marathon d'activité c'est un
cadre un peu ça ou d'une succession
d'activités sur scène dont on
al'avantage alors un gymnase et puis
quelques structures à côté une
succession d'activités de spectacle le
vendredi ça va débuter avec wade
animations ça va en fait débuté à 18h30
18h les installations du
du tennis-club retour au gymnase à 19h
et la amis de la flûte et puis ensuite
dans ce spectacle et ça se terminera par
un concert donc prochainement de
spectacle le vendredi soir le samedi a
notamment gelé noter une randonnée
pédestre mais qui sera proposé lui
hannover démarrage heures randonnée
pédestre dans la vallée retour vers
11h30 12h fait une activité sur scène
vers 11h30 12h un loto le troisième loto
que nous organisons qui marche bien ça
permet de faire entrer un petit peu de
moyens de mener en fait et puis on
continue les activités et puis pendant
tout ce temps là on se restaure
bien sûr on se restaure le je pense que
le secret de la réussite sais pas si ça
va être une de vos questions de secret
de la réussite c'est faire un moment
festif et avant tout nous souhaitons
faire un moment festif par rapport à mai
mois quitterait on parle de la maladie
forcément cessé de la fête avant tout de
la solidarité tout à fait c'est ça si on
veut faire si on fait un moment festif
et bien les gens viennent les gens
viennent et ils entendent des messages
et il participe à cette grosse collecte
et voulait vu le site de magny les
hameaux qui s'affichait pour trouver
tout le programme complet alors du côté
de guyancourt serge polluants grosse
organisation également il ya des
animations qui ont déjà débuté depuis la
semaine dernière voilà il ya des erreurs
des manifestations qui ont déjà débuté
deux personnes derrière bon je vais
passer très rapidement les points forts
et tous adorent demain soir il ya un
repas exotique avec karaoké soirée
dansante à dans une maison de quartier
yves montand la maison de quartier dont
on peut réserver pour un repas exotique
préparé par une dame malgaches dont on
peut l'appeler au 06 62 47 04 81 je
répète
06 62 47 04 90 86 religieux dont de
consulter le site
alors les points forts stone demain on a
deux points forts danser sur le papillon
waldeck rousseau et sur le gymnase de
l'aviation à ce sera samedi c'est oui
pardon c'est ça me dit dans 8 décembre
donc au
au gymnase de l'aviation dont il y aura
d'abord une promenade découverte à 13h30
alors les points fort bon il ya du baby
mi-temps du basket du tennis de table
une association de non voyants qui va
nous faire faire des choses à des chiens
et cetera des dégustations il ya les
échecs de guyancourt avec une personne
qui va jouer en simultané peu contre
plusieurs
disons candidat disant plusieurs
personnes dont classé très sport sur les
pressions dans cet espoir est né de la
mer etc
il ya de la réflexologie des massages
disant il ya des dames qui viennent pour
détendre les gens voient là et après dix
ans au pavillon avec rousseau dans ses
vacances à 17 heures par un concert de
gospel bon on a la chance d'avoir une
très grande chorale de gospel avec 80
choristes et six musiciens sur scène à
chaque année on le fait depuis trois ans
dont il attire beaucoup de monde
ensuite c'est pareil en un excellent
pour le spectacle de cirque qui avait
que l'étoile de gymnastique de devis en
cours et entre sir que ça s'appelle dont
ce sont des jeunes gens qui font du
trapèze
vous savez s'enroule autour du tissu la
caf se déroule et c'est très
spectaculaire c'est fantastique et le
soir dont après il y aura dans la soirée
des associations à des spectacles de
danse en flash mob l'accordéon de très
bonne qualité et qu'on me dit monsieur
de ya de la restauration en même temps
les gens peuvent venir manger boire sous
forme de snacking quoi voilà donc deux
lieux on le rappelle le gymnaste de
l'aviation et le pavillon vert samedi on
peut retrouver tout le programme sur le
site internet de lg deuxième j'ai très
rapidement un mot les ingrédients de la
réussite on l'a dit ça soit une grande
fête
oui en effet c'est un moment festif
voilà faut que les gens ne viennent
vraiment dans la joie et la bonne humeur
parce que je crois que les malades les
chercheurs mois que j'ai rencontré
personnellement dans le cadre de ma
famille tout ça de d'enfants malades
il n'a rien se dire que ça s'est
toujours être dans la joie la bonne
humeur et c'est merci serge furieuse en
est et daniel tu as même d'être passé
sur ce plateau pour les téléthons ayant
cours et magny les hameaux le 32e
téléthon est lancée à partir de demain
et si vous ne pouvez pas vous rendre à
lyon court ou magny les hameaux
vous pouvez faire également un don sur
ce numéro le 36 37
le portrait de la semaine c'est tout de
suite
et ce soir rencontre avec lauriane prime
au lit elle est éducatrice canin et
comportementaliste à guyancourt un
métier qu'elle a commencé à exercer en
septembre dernier après avoir effectué
une reconversion professionnelle une
rencontre signé michael et demi d'euros
et nicolas landry lauriane primes liées
et éducatrices et comportementaliste
pour chiens c'est sa quatrième séance
avec olea berger australien de dix mois
le problème de cette chaîne l'obéissance
de base olea c'est bien fils est bien au
pied c'est bien très bien
c'est une chaîne qui saute beaucoup
décalé dès qu'elle est malade et qu'elle
a envie de jouer dès qu'elle est
contente elle voilà c'est comme ça
qu'est elle a du mal à canaliser son
énergie
l'objectif c'est de lui montrer qu'il ya
des temps de jeu mais aussi des temps
voilà où vous écouter à 32 ans est
bruyant courtoise a créé sa micro
entreprise en septembre 2010 huit
conseils d'éducation pour chiens
compréhension du comportement avec des
exercices pour faire comprendre
l'obéissance à l'animal souvent l'erreur
qui a commencé quand un show on lui
autorise tout parce qu'il est petit sauf
que il ne faut pas oublier qu'un chiot
s'agrandit et que bah quand il est gros
lui il a été habitué à certaines choses
et après le retour en arrière est plus
difficile donc vaut mieux habitués à un
show tout de suite à certaines règles
que plus tard que je pense qu'en
fonction du caractère du chien en
fonction de la race on doit adapter
aussi certaines certaines choses moi moi
même je n'applique pas toujours la même
chose forcément en fonction des chiens
j'ai toujours une base mais ces
variables ces techniques lorien les a
apprises lors de sa reconversion
professionnelle un changement de voie et
un changement de vie choisi le métier
que je fais enfin en fait nous permet
vraiment de compléter et mon métier
d'éducateur canin et de m'occuper quand
même une de mes enfants qui va qui sont
encore très petit et ça me permet pas de
partager beaucoup ma vie avec eux et
partager beaucoup de moments c'est des
fiches comme ça et je m'amuse et en fait
à reproduire ces fiches là prêts à les
résumés dans mon classeur les animaux
c'est une passion depuis son plus jeune
âge après le bac et deux ans de faculté
de droit
lauriane primo lire entre en école de
commerce après avoir obtenu son diplôme
elle intègre une agence de relations
presse basée à puteaux vraiment j'ai été
contente mais sans plus voilà j'étais
c'est pas à cause fin pas forcément à
cause de lagence pas forcément à cause
du boulot en lui-même
c'était vraiment juste je me suis dit je
ne me vois pas faire ça toute ma vie
j'ai besoin de pouvoir autre chose de
bouger de d'être plus pas à confronter à
l'internet à la nature chose que je
voulais faire et en plus jeunes avant
même que j'attaque tout mes grandes
études ont ce côté la communication
marketing m'a toujours intéressé et
encore même aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
ça me sert de base pour créer mon site
internet pour m'occuper des réseaux
sociaux de bas de ma société
après avoir obtenu des renseignements
pour engager sa reconversion
elles financent sa formation a good and
park pour devenir éducateur canin et
comportementaliste des compétences
acquises entre le mois d'août 2010 est
et juin 2018 avec la possibilité de
s'occuper de ses enfants qui une partie
théorique qui se fait à la maison et
après un côté pratique donc une
formation pratique où on va dans le jura
est on bosse en fait les acquis depuis
le lancement de sa micro-entreprise
l'éducatrice canin guyancourt toise a
signé six contrats de clients soit entre
6 et 8 rendez vous par semaine
ce programme a été lancé tout récemment
dans les yvelines silver fourchette
organise des animations autour de
l'alimentation des seniors point d'orgue
un concours de gastronomie entre les
chefs des ehpad des yvelines finale
départementale fin février à guyancourt
alors pour en parler
une invités en plateau il honore
padovani bonsoir vous êtes chef de
projet silver fourchette chine
or derrière le programme de silver
fourchette c'est une association le
groupe sos seniors un mot déjà sur cette
association
quelles sont ses missions donc le projet
effritement silver fourchette a été
lancée en 2014 par l'association groupe
sos seniors qui est donc une association
gestionnaire de services et
établissements pour personnes âgées ont
principalement des ehpad d'accord et le
programme silver fourchette en quoi
consiste-t-il donc c'est un programme de
promotion de l'alimentation santé pied
d'alimentation plaisir et santé à
destination de toute personne de plus de
60 ans dont qui se déploie dans une
quinzaine de départements
avec un festival d'animations culinaires
tout tournait autour du bien manger pour
bien dire
on parle souvent des sujets
d'alimentation pour tous les âges
pourquoi chez les seniors le ce sujet de
l'alimentation et est il important parce
que l'alimentation c'est un des éléments
essentiels du bien vieillir
voilà faut savoir que un tiers des
personnes qui arrivent en ehpad son tour
un état de dénutrition
donc c'est pour ça bref tout un
programme de sensibilisation de
prévention de la dénutrition à
destination seulement des personnes en
résidence mais également des personnes
des personnes seniors à domicile donc
ces lauréats prendre certains réflexes
lors donner quelques conseils à me
donner des clés en fait pour bien se
nourrir
après 60 ans alors l'objectif j'imagine
c'est de se développer sur le tout le
territoire c'est pour ça que silver
fourchette arrive dans les yvelines
quand je vous disais on est présent dans
une quinzaine de départements et cette
année on se lance dans les yvelines avec
le soutien de la conférence des
financeurs de la prévention de la perte
d'autonomie des yvelines on a vraiment à
coeur cet ancrage local en fait pour
être au plus près du territoire
et voilà donc valoriser les initiatives
locales et mobiliser l'ensemble des
acteurs que ce soient des acteurs
institutionnels des établissements pour
personnes âgées des établissements de
formation pour les jeunes des
producteurs locaux des entreprises tous
mobilisés autour de ces problématiques
en fait de ces enjeux du bien manger à
l'événement fort qui va arriver c'est ce
concours de cuisine des chefs des ehpad
des yvelines quels sont les objectifs
c'est de créer l'événement finalement
autour de ce programme cybers fourchette
donc les objectifs de ce concours c'est
donc de mettre en lumière en fait les
métiers de la restauration en
collectivité notamment auprès des jeunes
puisque ce sont des établissements de
formation qui accueille le concours
d'accord dans une dynamique
intergénérationnelle
d'autre part c'est de mobiliser
l'ensemble des établissements pour
personnes âgées autour d'un vrai projet
d'établissement autour du bien manger
toujours de manière ludique et
conviviale et voilà donc proposer un
événement festif
convivial et gourmand à l'ensemble des
résidents des équipes des établissements
et puis des établissements de formation
et ça va se dérouler en trois étapes
l'an née dans l'avant première cette
semaine que s'est il passé cette semaine
exactement l'avant-première c'est la
première étape du concours silver
fourchette c'était en fait une série
d'animations qui se passe dans les ehpad
dans les résidences pour personnes âgées
voilà on propose toute une série
d'animations pour mobiliser l'ensemble
de l'établissement autour de ce projet
dans cette dynamique
cette semaine a eu lieu la première
avant-première du concours elle n'est
pas de les oiseaux à sartrouville
d'accord ou l'ensemble de la direction
des services financiers du secrétariat
du personnel de soin de la cuisine et
des animes des animations des familles
aussi se sont mobilisés pour une semaine
d'animations et hier a eu lieu le grand
repas festif de la semaine où j'étais
présente qu'il est à la salle à manger
était entièrement aux couleurs du
concours tous les alizés d'emporter des
petites fleurs en papier réalisés
pendant les ateliers de la semaine y
avait une banderole réalisé également
pendant les ateliers
c'est finalement un événement de
lancement les autres étapes du concours
donc après l'avant-première les
établissements sont invités à nous
envoyer un candidat pour la sélection
départementale donc le candidat ça peut
être où le chef de cuisine option second
ou toute personne non professionnels du
monde de la cuisine qui veut représenter
son établissement au cours du
concours donc ils sont invités à
rejoindre des brigades les brigades ces
trois personnes donc un chef
involontaire gastronomes toute personne
non professionnel et un jeune d'accord
qui vont être formés le jour de la
sélection départementale et donc avant
courrier pendant trois heures autour du
thème grain de folie et soumettront
proposeront leurs plats et leur dessert
donc un plat et un dessert décliner
chacun en quatre assiettes au jury
technique et au jury dégustation
en parallèle les résidents sont invités
à participer à un comité de soutien pour
soutenir leur candidat et participer à
différents ateliers et donc la finale
départementale il nous reste déjà une
minute dans cet entretien elle se
déroulera au cfa trajectoire de
guyancourt en février même principe que
la sélection départementale et à côté de
ce concours il ya aussi d'autres
animations qui vont être proposées sur
cale port nationalisé il ya aussi un
volet qui s'adresse plutôt aux seniors à
domicile donc des ateliers cuisine des
conférences débats et des ateliers
intergénérationnels qui se passeront
dans les villes de bus climat vélizy
viroflay versailles non toutes les
informations sur ces événements sont sur
notre site internet silver fourchette
point org qui est en train de s'afficher
peut-être ça y est ils s'affichent ce
site internet merci et l'honore padovani
d'être passé sur ce plateau
merci navarre à qui je rappelle que vous
êtes chef de projet silver fourchette
yvelines on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler de ce projet et puis pour
terminer ce journal après les
commémorations de la première guerre
mondiale vont débuter celle de la
seconde à cette occasion elle les
archives départementales des yvelines
ont décidé de créer un jeu de société un
jeu plateau autour de la résistance en
seine et oise le public est amené à
contribuer à ce projet ancré en lui même
son son jeu la première séance avait
lieu hier soir au sein même des archives
on voit tous avec mélanie poké soirée
studieuse yvelinois découvre le monde du
jeu de société du produit fini à la
création
première étape avant de créer soi-même
son jeu
auteur au tri de jeux de société c'est
vraiment un métier c'est un savoir faire
et comme tout métier tout savoir-faire
bassa se découvre et ça s'apprend donc
nous c'est vrai qu'on a on n'a pas la
prétention de
dire que on va faire en sorte que les
gens deviennent hauteur au tri sans
quelques ateliers
mais l'idée c'est qu'ils puissent
découvrir un peu les rouages les
mécanismes faut penser à toutes vos
pensées à tous mais surtout à ses
joueurs et à ses joueuses deux ans de
travail sont nécessaires dans le monde
professionnel ces participants auront
quelques mois pour réfléchir autour de
la résistance créé un jeu sur la
thématique de l'histoire ça faisait deux
choses vraiment intéressantes qui m'ont
poussé à participer
je trouve ça intéressant quand même de
voir comment on adapte justement un
thème dans derrière des mécaniques de
jeu comme on intéresse les les
participants les joueurs au thème via le
jeu en avril ils présenteront un jeu
historique autour de réseaux la version
plateau pensé par les archives
départementales et conçu par un
professeur d'histoire géographie
on va mettre en exergue en fait dans ce
jeu la difficulté ne résiste et le fait
que c'était extrêmement compliqué de se
procurer les moyens de résister bien sûr
on était face à l'adversité on pouvait
risquer de se faire arrêter voire pire
donc c est la dangerosité qu'on essaie
de faire passer et les typologies de
d'action qu'on pouvait faire de la
propagande à savoir distribuer
simplement des tracts jusqu'à des
actions armées du sabotage de plus
grande envergure réseau doit sortir pour
la fin de l'année 2019 mais il pourrait
évoluer avec les idées fournis par
l'atelier 11 autres séances sont prévues
la prochaine est organisée le mercredi
12 décembre
c'est la fin de ce journal le replay à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile les idées de
sorties du week-end c'est à retrouver
dans un instant dans l'émission 7 8
loisirs présenté par marylène iapichino
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]